[Music]
in crazy Kanye news I like this one but
let's go submitted by Marjorie from
Malaysia Malaysia Kanye West's slavery
was a choice amongst other crazy things
he said lately said yeah it's so
interesting I mean there's like context
to it yeah there's definitely context to
it like I understand why he said it or
like the the wrappings around it yeah
he's just really responsible he
delivered it he delivered it very bad
sentence slavery was a choice is a poor
choice so it's it's [ __ ] up in so many
ways because I saw the whole 30 minute
interview with TMZ right and I mean I
understood a hundred [ __ ] percent what
he was trying to say but as an artist
sometimes we don't convey things with
words really well that's why he's a
genius music what was he saying 100% oh
I'll show you a compilation clip of this
TMZ interview because it's like yes
please because I haven't watched it yet
so you guys can all be on the same page
thank you
but yeah I'll bring it I'll bring it
close to home though but Shh let's watch
are you here about slavery for 400 years
for 400 years that's not like a choice
for 400 years and it's all y'all feel
like what the [ __ ] it's like we're we're
mentally in prison I like the word
prison cuz slavery that's where he tries
to correct themselves to direct to the
idea of blacks it's like slavery
Holocaust Holocaust Jews slavery is
blacks so prison is something that
unites us is one race blacks and whites
being one race that we're one with a
human race that was drugged the [ __ ] out
bro I was drugged out I was on opioids
two days after I got off of opioids and
I was addicted to opioids two days I got
off for opioids I'm in the hospital
right so this is in reference to the
Twitter rant you know we all tor give me
some weed Beauvoir so he had to go give
me the opioids and there was talks
amongst my camp like yeah he's popping
J's popping pills right so when he
handed to me this to me said you know
this is used to kill genius right so I
didn't take it two days later I'm in a
hospital I was taking two pills a day at
that time when I left the hospital how
many pills you think I was given seven
seven and I'm not drugged out this these
pills that they want me to take three
other day I take one a week maybe two a
week y'all had me scared of myself of my
vision so I took some pills so I
wouldn't go to hospital and prove
everyone right
we are drugged out
we are following other people's opinions
we are controlled by the media and today
it all changes so that's % it's funny
because you know he's a package and
crazy you know but there's like these
jewels of wisdom in there it's just he's
just crazy that it sounds like he had a
speech like that he wrote and then he
memorized it but then it's just coming
out wrong place it's coming out horrible
but the way I agree with you I do too I
do too
so we face this problem on jakie news
all the time yeah so sometimes we only
have a split second to [ __ ] make a
statement we [ __ ] it all up we say some
stupid ass [ __ ] we don't really mean it
but then it comes out all wrong and then
people mistake what we said and they get
all angry right but that's our fault for
not conveying the message in this case
it's the same exact thing he immediately
retracted his statement and said no I
don't want to tie it to slavery I want
to talk about all mental prison so in
that statement he wasn't saying that you
know black people wanted to be sleep I
heard him he walked it back right after
I said
but everyone's grabbing that they're so
stuck there so stuck on the on the on
the point that Oh Connie thinks all
black people had a choice to be a slave
right and that's what we all do right
like I like I'll say something say oh
here right and then I I'm like well
that's not quite what I mean not only my
lab right on that and they don't take
the elaborate I know they take no no no
you [ __ ] up you said that's the game
yeah he's trying so many times to like
like to basically say no this is what I
really meant and people are not taking
his explanation well most news clips
will take what he just said right there
and cut it Brampton oh yeah that's what
they've been doing they've been doing
that's not the reason why he's
misunderstood though like he already had
a precedence before that - how it ended
up people listening to his information
how it is now so if you look at his
Twitter rants if you look at how he was
before so if you look in that whole
interview he's screaming the whole time
he's beautiful he's passionate yeah he's
like attention I don't know if he's
screaming but you're definitely
demanding and he's no he's screaming
throughout the heels Oh TMZ
everybody listen that's what he was
doing in the whole video if you watch
the 30 minute video think I was here and
he was screaming at everything well
that's another part but yeah so yeah you
know when you come from like an
emotionally charged area of course
things are gonna become like
misinterpreted yeah so I do understand
everybody else's side as well but you
know we like you know like Joseph we all
face that [ __ ] like to be [ __ ] yeah like
just the other day like I was on Twitter
and then like you know they were talking
about that girl with the the the dress
the dress right a lot of people have
been complaining about it and I just
wrote boo who was intellectual way
possible just havin a good point and
this guy wrote back to me he goes he
goes he called me a [ __ ] neo-nazi how
did you go so I was I just wrote what
the [ __ ] are you talking about he goes
well did you know so there's other Asian
girl who supported her but she was
saying like I can't believe you chinks
are met but I mean she was really
extremely she's wearing a trump hat and
he goes well now that you're friends
with that girl hold on
so they took this thing and they dragged
me all the way over here and that's just
what people are it's like you know what
if you it's the popular thing to be
angry now yes I think it's cool to be
able but if it's funny absolutely it's
the popular thing to tell people why
they think something without letting
them explain themselves
exactly here's why you're in
see even though you didn't say anything
about being an Ian on but here's why you
are one so and that's what the media did
this whole past couple years man they're
just telling everybody here why if you
voted for Trump you're a racist sexist
homophobic blah blah blah it's llama
phobic everything phobic exactly so when
he wrote that comment I had a backtrack
to figure out how he got to that point
baby so he goes this is who your support
up I'll say wait who's this girl I was
talking about the girl who wore the
dress he goes don't act like you don't
know what I'm talking about I'm like
like that guys just crazy look like I
don't know what you're talking about
and then there was this other point
where this kid brought up I was like you
know something he was trying to be you
know really straightforward about it and
so I just had a conversation with him on
Twitter and he was like well what if I
somebody said it was like a black person
bla bla bla and I was like listen we got
to stop doing this comparison about
Asian culture and black culture because
black culture here we're talking about
slavery we're talking about all this
other stuff that it's it's different to
saying it's it's apples and oranges you
know and we're talking about some
something where people are talking about
they're at a socio-economic disadvantage
if he writes back he goes well
apparently you haven't heard about it
the Asian words and long it allows
people I said socio-economic not
economic you dumb [ __ ] you don't know
the [ __ ] difference like it and it's
like they're trying to have like this
intellectual conversation with me but
they don't even know how to bring up
points that are correct they don't know
what socio-economic is he tried using a
sentence you know it's like what the
[ __ ] well that's I think one of the main
reasons why you're appropriately wagga
wagga hat he wore the mag aha and he
explained it to he's like I'm not
political he goes but he said that he
said in the most stupidest way he was
like the universe was telling me to wear
a hat right that's that's the stupid he
believed in the message like he wants to
make America great to it like he was
saying like you know Trump is my my boy
like back in the day all the rappers we
always rap about it and that was a thing
with rap like including Trump and then
now all of a sudden he's president now
no one can like him but I think the
biggest thing that he rose is why do
blacks have to be liberal
why do minorities have to be like we're
born into the [ __ ] and we're
programmed to be democratic we have to
or else we're backstabbing our culture
or else we're joining the white racists
that are Republican I've met a lot of
Republican white people that
[ __ ] races at all and I'm like what
Wyatt will you met the rare ones cuz
they're all racist that's the game
welcome to the close my [ __ ] mind
because like look I think how did this
thought come into my head there's a bend
I think of the left that is not
necessarily the left right like it's
like the loudest people on the left are
basically saying like hey if you're a
woman and you vote for a Republican like
Hillary said if you're a woman and yeah
like you're controlled by your husband
and you voted for Trump or your vote
Republican
you're controlled by your husband which
is insulting this [ __ ] right but it's
like it's like if you're a woman you're
not a woman if you vote for Republicans
if you're a gay person you're not a gay
person if you vote Republicans if you're
black you're not a black person if you
vote for Republicans and that's just the
game right if you're Asian you're not
Asian if you vote and so they don't
they'll be happy to call you every
racist name in the book and I'm not
saying all of them do I'm saying the
minority to loud minority do that right
the majority I think are all being quiet
too which is why a lot of people have
been pushed into the center people I
feel like myself yeah where I'm like hey
I'm not I don't want I want people to be
able to say what the [ __ ] they think
yeah what happened to that like the left
used to be about that and now it's all
like shut the [ __ ] up if you don't agree
with everything I'm saying yeah you're
oppressing me you're a Nazi it's like if
you don't agree with if you don't agree
with like this certain like it's like if
Asian if every Asian person is doing
this if you're not following them then
you're a pacifist you know it's like how
about I just don't give a [ __ ] you know
I mean how about I could just not give a
[ __ ] how about I'm just a human above
being Asian yeah everyone's just the
human dealing why do you have to be fit
into these little categories that's I
mean that's the main point that he was
trying to make is he's trying to stir it
up like hey how come I can't be free to
choose and support Trump I'm black but
then do I have to be Democrat I don't I
don't agree with everything he's saying
yeah he doesn't even care about politics
he just likes him as a human being but
you know how the media talk so it's like
if you're a woman and you're against
abortion you're not for women you're
against one right it's like that's it's
a difference of opinion of beliefs right
and then you are out of the it's all
tribalism and you're out of the tribe if
you don't think exactly like the rest of
the tribe and that's exactly what he was
communicating here is we're so stuck in
these groups and ideas of victimization
that
no one's empowered everyone thinks
they're empowered by complaining but in
reality you're just [ __ ] an echo
chamber just [ __ ] saying whatever the
[ __ ] you hear your group saying just
didn't are articulated well that's what
that's that's just my point is with him
is just like he is not a great speaker
you know what though in that same
interview there's this girl named
Candace Owens that came out super
[ __ ] elegant awesome person she was a
liberal like a year ago or something and
then she turned she got pushed to the
center yeah she's more centrist some
people say she's a right-wing hardcore
right-wing person but she she is not a
right winger from any definite I don't
think so no she doesn't even push right
agendas I think that the left got so
left kind of like how when George W was
in charge the right cut so right that it
was like Jesus Christ guys he's like
[ __ ] we got to go blow up every single
country in the Middle East now like like
like it just got I mean I was not fan
right so so I think like that's what
happened to left they got too far that
that other way and now everyone on the
left is getting pushed into the middle
it's almost like he needs it you know
what he needs he needs a Luther you know
that [ __ ] anger translator oh he'll
sketch with the but he needs somebody to
translate what he wants to say because
he goes at it a little too hard with
just no context and there's too much
emotion in his speech so like we can
understand what he's thinking and I'm
saying to him it's like if you just
don't want to be misunderstood and you
want that message to get across you got
a package it better you know he made
packaged it better he made black people
feel backstab that's where he [ __ ] up
there what do you tweet it out we had
freedom of speech but not freedom of
thought the thought police want to
suppress freedom of thought there was a
time when slavery was the trend and
apparently that time is still abundant
upon us but now it's a mentality yeah
that's pretty good that's pretty [ __ ]
good that was better he did saying he
writes his curses and curses in one of
his song lyrics and I liked it you know
you know what though once you [ __ ] up a
statement though people have such a bad
feeling they don't even want to hear it
cool that's how the media that's what
the media does I think what also made it
so bad I mean as we can all agree in
this room is so
made that statement then followed it by
I was [ __ ] high in a decrease opioids
and then he's talking about I got
liposuction because of you guys so all
of that altogether for the the average
thinker they're just like yo he lost it
and now anyone that was semi race this
is now thinking yeah man like black
people it is just the [ __ ] choice
like slavery is just all [ __ ] like
they're just putting themselves in that
position and it's like oh no like you
just open up like what have you listen
to him like yeah you're smart well we're
no but if you listen him to liposuction
[ __ ] like you go to the supermarket
right and you're you're staying in line
and you look to your left at the
checkout and every single cover is like
about what celebrity got fat this week
like every [ __ ] single celebrity got
fat right but but that's why Kanye was
like you guys did this [ __ ] to me like
the median he's talking the media he
mentioned Rob Kardashian how he he cried
attend the wedding because people were
because he gained weight the people the
average the average person doesn't see
it like that they don't even understand
what that even means I think the point
is it's just like he is not doing his
job as somebody who is he says he is
somebody who is so influential in this
bucket he really is what that title upon
himself so you put that title upon
yourself and you should be responsible
for what you say then if that's the case
you meant here is that he should be more
responsible with with what he only only
I only say that because he says he's the
most influential man on listen before
this slavery quote even came out this is
a very recent interview it just happened
like a like a couple couple days ago now
he can't he just was had all these
tweets before and they were already
calling him crazy they were already out
there saying how crazy he was and then
the family like they were like Kanye's
lost at this time the family's super
concerned and like he got into huge
arguments with Kris Jenner and [ __ ] and
then Kris Jenner - II didn't know he
didn't this isn't real what the [ __ ] you
guys talking about
like this has been the media plan this
whole time like hey
Kanye's crazy crazy Kanye again here
comes crazy Kanye
so the slavery thing this exact quote is
this the now the Billboard right will
blow it up as big as we can
other group of people also saying like
you know it kynesha nobody's doing he
was an album coming out he's just
stirring the pot just like the last time
he was away from Twitter for a long-ass
time and he came back up - I'm almost
100% sure about that - just because he
has a whole [ __ ] PR team around him
and the PR team if the if he would he
was doing crazy [ __ ] that wasn't good
for his career they would stop them by
now so I'm pretty sure it's and he's
also making another point of another
tweet saying like yo like what like just
remember all the distractions like
there's some other [ __ ] that's going on
but because you're paying attention to
this distraction then you already forgot
about what's really happening in this
world oh yeah that's what Candice is
saying you're just focusing on the
tiniest little like police brutality and
stuff and there's like all this other
bigger things I'm yawning yeah look at
Chicago nobody cares what Chicago nobody
cares about dead kids in Chicago happens
all the time
[ __ ] murder murder capital capital
America
what is it 350 it's [ __ ] insane 350
people die of gun violence like every
weekend arson or some no no no not in
Chicago I think it's like from from ryf
or from assault rifles right it's like
350 people a year you think Oh Oh
nationwide nationwide ban guns is like
what the whole but everyone zooming in
so [ __ ] hard on that while people
died in Chicago nobody gives a [ __ ] but
that's the [ __ ] that that you can't its
owns it's pretty crazy
[Music]